que faisiez-vous à dimanche dernier ce
que vous êtes allé au grand vide
greniers de montils bretonne fille dont
j'aurais pu parce que je pense que
j'aurais fait des affaires eh bien oui
c'est ce que nous allons voir on va
revenir sur ce grand vide grenier qui a
eu lieu donc le dimanche organisée par
la ville de montigny le bretonneux alors
c'est un rendez vous incontournable pour
tous les chineurs de la région puisque
c'était la 30e édition cette année et
malgré la météo comme vous le voyez le
dise il y avait beaucoup de monde
c'était l'occasion de vendre des meubles
de l'électroménager des livres et des
dvd mais aussi de faire des bonnes
affaires comme des vêtements ou encore à
des baskets presque neuf pour une
modique somme de 5 euros
alors comme thérèse 85 ans elle est
venue brader ses affaires on écoute 2
brocanteuse de ce vide-greniers
ah bah moi ça m'intéresse jamais j'étais
dans le commerce quand j'étais jeune et
j'ai toujours gardé le contact des gens
alors pour moi c'est un plaisir puis
j'ai vu que ça à faire un
c'est surtout pour me débarrasser un
petit peu de tout ce que j'ai j'ai
beaucoup de choses
il ya des gens qui viennent de partout
il ya beaucoup d'acheteurs qui viennent
de paris d'ailleurs c'est pas que des
gens de 78 et des gens vraiment qu'ils
viennent d'ailleurs ce qu'ils sont il
aime beaucoup les brocantes et des cas
une brocante acquise ici pointe